I was not going to let the State of
Florida descend into some type of
falchian dystopia where people's
freedoms were curtailed and their
livelihoods were destroyed no we stood
up for people's rights we protected
people's jobs and small businesses and
guaranteed like your Governor did that
kids had a right to be in school and get
an education in person five days a week
in short Florida we chose Freedom over
faucism and we are better off for having
done that it seems like these speeches
were written by some kind of poor like
by chat GPT one you know it's not even
like the stuff that three or four can
write for them and it just does not have
winner written anywhere all over it by
the way for all of his bragging about
kovid Florida with the 10th highest per
capita coveted death rate 10th highest
per capita covet death rate so not
exactly something to brag about